i was a huge fan of love different
robots to get asked to do first sequel
in the bunch of uh love death and robots
was neat you look at this you go how is
it done it's like a million techniques
merging into one
this is entirely 2d i would guess
there's no evidence in here of it being
3d so we're looking at a piece here
that's 3d it's cg but it's shaded to
look like it's a cartoon tune shading
can you define what that is technically
for us
this video is brought to you by hong
kong impact stick around to the end to
see how you can get some cool stuff for
free
hey welcome back to another episode of
animators react we have a very special
guest today by the fact there's actually
two guests we have alex snow and patrick
osborne incredible artists animators
directors even you know what i'm gonna
let these guys do the introductions i'm
alex snow i'm an animator currently
working on strange world of disney i
also am a founder at double plus
productions doing mainly 2d animation
for commercial work series film wait
patrick who are you i'm patrick osborne
i am an animator and uh director i
animated at places like sony imageworks
for a long time and disney and i've
recently been doing stuff out on my own
they blur for example and love death and
robots oh cool love death and robots is
requested so many times on the show and
we finally have somebody worked on an
episode here so now we can actually talk
about it in depth love doesn't robots is
pretty unique i think like tim miller
he's a really awesome animator and
director himself he'll go after an idea
for years like loved other robots is 12
or 13 years of trying to get this kind
of thing made his general approach is
like this story works really cool on the
page what if i paired it with this
director and see what they do and what's
really neat is it's a mix of the
directors come from all kind of
different creative backgrounds i'm an
animator some of them are vfx soups some
are like story artists let's start with
yours sure i mean i was a huge fan of
love different robots to get asked to do
first sequel in the bunch of uh love
death and robots was was neat
welcome to the unsinkable libertarian
dream that is seasteading this is made
by a small studio in spain called blow
studio now i like to be a little bit
hands on and know the software they use
they use 3ds max 3ds max wow i
know nothing about 3ds max so this was a
really technically hands-off for me this
is one of the favorites it's why they
would make a sequel so you don't want to
ruin it you don't want to do anything
too silly that feels out of the style
but also you got to build on it somehow
it's a little bit tricky like what is a
fresh look on the post apocalypse i
really did like the idea of doing like
an oil rig paradise seastead thing yeah
i felt like that i hadn't really seen in
any video game or anything yeah when
you're going into direct a short
animated film do you need to get as
close to nailing that short down before
you actually animate it right yeah so
how do you do that he's storyboarded a
lot so you basically just make a janky
animated version of it first yeah you
hand draw storyboards with hopefully a
team try to cut together a visual plan
for the whole movie and that way
everyone knows what set needs to be
built what needs to be drawn what can be
a map painting it's all kind of like bit
out from that storyboard you kind of
plan it from the script too budgetarily
but storyboard focuses it a lot more
like so much of directing is like
selling and pitching and working on
story and getting artwork together and
that's all scrappy and there's something
really nice about just making a movie
that is usually just the very end so the
idea of like making the shots and making
the performance work and cutting it
together so satisfying that it's a dream
to do this kind of stuff so if these
tech millionaires have been just a
little more socially inclusive each of
the characters have kind of like a set
of rules or what they're allowed to move
like and i mean obviously these three
move very differently both because of
their proportions but also they're
here's a pyramid yeah and one is a
pyramid drone they do have kind of they
have character rules like the little guy
is based on a baby monitor is designed
so it's like he's a lot more hopeful the
pyramid is kind of the smartest and the
most kind of like factual and
down-to-earth and the x-bot the humanoid
one kind of sees himself as like
human-like and they move similarly to
that i mean there's a jumpy bounciness
to the orange guy to kvrc and the xbox
very humanoid what was your rule for
like where the eyeball should be for
which emotion on pyramid guy you
literally just have a y-axis there's not
a lot there that character doesn't emote
much so you know i never i never was
like that character needs to feel happy
i mean it's a bad answer but like well
it seems a little cool because like if
you think of baymax who you think of as
like lots of character his face doesn't
change yeah it's just eyes the xbox just
has a jaw that opens up and down yeah i
mean they're pretty limited when you
really look at what's moving but it
doesn't feel that way you guys i think
one of these rockets actually launched
come check this out my goal with this
whole thing is like i'm an emotional
filmmaker like the stuff that i like to
do like i like trying to pull a little
bit of something so i do like that at
the end of this short there's a little
hint of like these robots being like do
i feel something is there something in
the the kind of ambition of humans to
leave and like all of that right i
wonder if elon musk has seen this
he made it you think he's the real
director
if you look at this you go how is it
done it's like a million techniques
merging into one it's hard to describe a
specific thing so robert valley awesome
illustrator he animates in photoshop
mostly which is unbelievable and he's
got like tutorials out there so you guys
can go see how it's literally done it's
mostly just amazing talent and time i
mean he's just doing so much to get this
to work the way it does and it works
like nothing else you've seen it's
warping things it's doing puppetry on
things it's keeping things simplistic
like that guy yelling is just a
silhouette puppet the use of gradients
in all the drawings just really changes
it from being a hand-drawn stuff you see
everywhere else so it's definitely like
one of those extremely well planned the
case when you're doing an illustrative
style like this where everything's very
intentional and any frame looks like an
amazing illustration comic book page
yeah i mean if you watch his older stuff
like pear cider and cigarettes it's very
much this but animated like cheap after
effects just kind of moving parts and
puppetry but this takes it to another
level like the traditional animation
details of how the characters are moving
and then still being able to do the
render work he's kind of evolved it to
the next stage
okay stop
whales don't like the machines i love
that he's every image feels so unified
in what robert valley does like that is
the compositing it's like the layers of
little bit of grain little chromatic
aberration on the edges of things that
kind of like squish it all into a
finished image
[Music]
i think one thing that's kind of
overlooked is the creator the director
really knows how the stuff is made yeah
and like all of his choices and planning
along the way of getting to the end know
what's hard to redo and what takes the
time and what doesn't there's something
special about being able to do it
because he actually like knows how to do
it when you talk about like stylistic 3d
versus hand-drawn 2d 3d tends to be more
forgiving on the direct ability side in
a lot of ways like you can change your
mind later right this stuff is really
hard to change your mind
down the road you know like you have to
redraw a lot if you realize the shot
doesn't work and that's why i say like
the director doing this it's great that
he kind of invented the technique and
made it his own because as a director
you don't want to make a call that is
like very expensive call an accident
about time we head back to the lander oh
come on burton this one is uh it's 3d
but there's hand-drawn elements on top
of it directed by emily dean this is i
believe her directorial debut the idea
of kind of taking on a look that is
challenging and so beloved by the
animation world is is really
cool and bold mobius is an illustrator
that is referenced a ton in all kinds of
stuff fifth element yeah valerian is a
mobius story really beautiful stuff and
it's been inspiring filmmakers and i
think this short ended up looking really
beautiful
so we're looking at a piece here that's
3d it's cg but it's shaded to look like
it's a cartoon or tune shading can you
define what that is technically for us
yeah a lot of 3d animation is very photo
real so it's looking at all bounce light
and following the curvature of a 3d
object and giving realistic shading and
there are different ways to render where
you can actually make it where that
shading is not as real where it's
divided into a dark side and a light
side it's not like a feathered fall off
it's
hard yeah and it gives you a much more
comic book or cartoon or handmade look
in some ways because i mean that really
comes from the process of making comics
was labor intensive and it would take a
longer time to draw something real so
you would find these shorthands in how
to draw it it's weird that it's kind of
harder to do in 3d because everything
has pushed towards making things look
very realistic and dimensional
wake up
wake
up
tell me how you technically achieve this
look how do i do this okay i sit down on
my computer i can fire blender
i want to make it look like this you
know most programs most renderers have
various tune shades there's all kinds of
little plugins you can get blender
specifically you know it has that
freestyle line render is in there so i
think you're building your full body
character rig first like about here like
this distance and kind of figuring out
what your like line settings need to be
and it's probably a combination of a
little bit of texture painted lines that
you choose to show occasionally but that
exterior line is all created by a line
renderer like freestyle and blender and
you can make blends and stuff like you
create the shape or the texture or the
whatever and then you can dial in
how much it's on or off but you could
also have different levels where if you
change the let's say cheek line they're
creeping in from the ear towards the
mouth or the amount of lines even like
the crease between her nostril and her
mouth you know that's not always there
it creeps in to give it feel more
panicked the same thing in spider-verse
like whether you see that line or how
thick it is you can also do a curve on
the character so you can actually scale
it and stretch it and it's actually like
a rigged line if i was doing it like
those close-ups would be a custom rig
but then you could actually even draw on
top of it yeah and add a little extra so
you do like a few lines that are the
ones you know you're going to have no
matter what and then on top of it
drawing a layer of detail and for when
creases happen and stuff like that i
mean obviously they're making specific
choices with what tracks with the head
and the movement whereas something like
spider-verse maybe that decision isn't
definite but it seems like it's leaning
into its choices a little more how would
you achieve something like this
efficiently and you know take that art
form you're finding and attempt to match
it yeah i mean it starts with the
artwork you know you do a few frames of
what you're trying to do visually in
single still frames a lot of times the
conversation this kind of stuff is like
at this distance what do we draw at this
distance what do we draw right because
the faces generally need to be more
detailed as you get close to camera
right you'll see some close-ups here
that look clearly might even be hand
animated in the 3d shows itself but i
think it does it in an appealing way
this is kill team killis is directed by
jen nelson and jen is also the
supervising director of the entire
second and third season which means that
as a director working on the show she's
the one that you actually interact with
more than uh anyone else she's you know
looking at boards and giving notes in
there on my recording sessions with the
actors and stuff too so huge impact on
the series is coming from her
this is entirely 2d i would guess
there's no evidence in here of it being
3d i imagine it's digital it's drawn on
tablets but all by hand so there's a lot
of like cool camera stuff but that's all
compositing tricks like dropping things
out of focus doing some shake a little
grain the little aberration and the
lighting here and there and when we talk
about the tune shade stuff the computer
is kind of deciding where the dark and
light mask is based on placing a virtual
light when you're doing it by hand it's
someone like physically drawing a mask
basically draw a black and white image
that is just masking out where the light
hits on the characters and then you can
fill that with a solid color a gradient
like a blend from a dark to a light to
add a little bit more texture and
dimension to it does it also let you
easily just change light colors if you
want to after the fact yeah easily do
that flicker that you can see in there
that they're doing you know you want
that mask to be able to do stuff like
that you're doing hand work but you're
also kind of using modern tools yeah and
then on top of that you can also
composite like you do in cg or you know
real live action film using after
effects compositors do a lot of hard
work but they also are there at the
moment when like it looks great yeah and
get a lot of applause
like there's more applause and like a
finished shot looking amazing for that
compositor the animator's like long gone
on that shot
yeah this you see the mask right here
basically they're doing like a shadow
pass where you can kind of see what's
done by hand in that shot yeah so you
can see like that red line usually it's
done with a different color too so that
you can one it's on a different layer
but also so you can see where those
lines need to be but also here you can
see that light flooding in they don't
always do it like that it might just be
a line and then the team after knows
this side is dark and this side is light
but like we've been talking about
sometimes it lands on the animator to do
a little bit more
you sure that recall buttons
this episode did a really good job at
balancing its animation as well like
some shots are done more in a tv style
keeping things solid or at the same
angle to be more efficient while other
shots just go balls to the wall just
like insane 2d animation and craziness
so you got a whole team working on this
and you have these dudes they look like
they're drawn by the same person how do
you achieve that how do you keep it so
it's like these look like they're drawn
by one person for the entire series it's
the job of the animation supervisor and
animation director is to make it feel
like it comes out of a single voice in a
single hand and that comes from a lot of
character design like early on turning
those characters around knowing how they
look consistent tools and then skill
yeah people being good at it in 2d
you'll have the animation director will
and should be doing you know draw overs
to keep the character on model when
you're drawing
so like so an artist draws a picture of
the character for a frame yeah the
director steps was like
yeah
yeah i mean depending what show if it's
a commercial like the director is
probably also that could be the
animation director you know but on a
show like this they're the final system
so any notes or thoughts and ideas that
jen has given or that you expect from
jen because you know what you liked then
you're kind of the funneling both down
and up so knowing you know the limits of
that character looking at the expression
sheets can help you stay on model even
better but it does land on the character
leads and stuff to set you up for
success it does get harder the bigger
the team when you compare even this to
like a robert valley this is a big team
at a big studio it's still confined
compared to like a pixar but you got a
lot of moving pieces i'd definitely be
curious to know the actual difference
between the teams and like yeah approach
i have no idea each project in death and
robots kind of left to its own to figure
that out and do what's best for it
[Music]
this isn't a show this is a game
yeah that's right this episode is
brought to you by hong kong impact let
me tell you about some of the cool
things that they've got ready for you
this summer including first but not
least a new character
her name is vil v and she's got like
eight different minds in one head she's
got a lot of cool helical contraptions
and gears and stuff i love mechanics so
does she when in battle she actually
fights alongside her turrets and
switches positions while firing but oh
man once she gets on her chariot though
it's game over for nearby enemies
because she'll be slashing him up like
she's mowing the lawn she's a very
steampunk inspired character and seems
like a lot of fun also the game's got a
bunch of summer events this year and the
first event is called the summer
survival rhapsody side a and during the
event captains can mix and match flame
chasers and equip them with different
weapons for battle while rolling
multiple dice during the battle to score
points you can then deal damage to
enemies according to how many points you
get and if you play the event you'll
even get miss pink elf's new outfit the
summer miss elf but don't forget about
the second event they've got coming
called the summer beach melee
captains can actually bets on various
flame chasers to win rewards and finally
there's a login event all you gotta do
is just show up log in and you will get
the sakurai summer a new outfit for none
other than ushinso momento additionally
there's some new outfits for mobius and
pardo as well inspired by the sea
there's even some visual effects being
applied on the renders of their
characters and it is guaranteed in 10
drops you won't be waiting around
forever
once you download the game use the gift
code that we've put in our description
to unlock all of the summer vibes anyway
enjoy the summer vibes and thanks again
to honkai impact for sponsoring this
episode
oh i just heard the flush i think
they're coming back i gotta get out of
here
all right i need your help we have lots
of great animations to react to but i
want to react to some anime from the 80s
you know like kind of the prime time for
anime when like some really good stuff
was coming out and no one knew about it
and like i don't really know much about
anime from the 80s so if there's like an
amazingly animated anime from the 80s
please give us some suggestions down
below and of course you can suggest a
lot of stuff too we read all the
comments we take it all in it's all good
please leave a comment all right what an
amazing episode thank you so much for
joining us alex and patrick this time
we're shouting out patrick because alex
has been on the show so many times that
he's got plenty of shout outs
this is my shout out for patrick there
you go yeah the goon movie maybe keep an
eye out for it in like a few years in a
while you know yeah you can follow
patrick on twitter at uh patrickt
osborne and you know what i asked these
guys was there anything they wanted to
promote and they said no so i asked them
to recommend you guys a movie i would
recommend boy and the beast it's a
little old at this point but i just saw
it for the first time i thought it was a
really great traditionally animated
movie worth checking out i mean this
might be obvious right now but
everything everywhere all at once
everyone should see that i thought it
had to be animated i was stressed
well no there's an animated rock it blew
my mind it's such an amazing i want you
to get everyone here for an everywhere
all at once episode where it's stunt
people animation effects
everyone is here everyone every
we're here all at once
sweet well thank you so much for joining
us guys thank you so much for watching
consider subscribing we'll see you
either tomorrow on sunday for our sunday
video or next saturday for our next
react video